[inaudible]
but it's nice to be back.
I mean,
Google's one of my homes and it
feels really comfortable to be here.
Um,
hiring,
um, you know, when I, uh,
I have to just acknowledge,
I have my publisher here, uh,
Mark Tavor who's the publisher of Harper
one which is one of the imprints of
Harper Collins and the best imprint
because all those special books that you
read, the sacred books, the books
that had really deep meaning,
they published them and
they're on their lists.
So then it's something to really
think about. But I remember, um,
when I started writing this book,
which was about 35 years ago,
um,
any number of times I stopped writing
it in part because it was so much about
me. And, uh, as Gandhi said,
there becomes a moment when the self
is too much with you and you can't even
abide it.
So there's no way in the world that I
would agree to have my photo on a book or
to have my name on it.
Here it is my photo and my name and a
lot of the things about writing a book
become weird when you're writing a memoir,
but about a year ago,
because of the vitriol,
the anger, the hatred,
the Shazam that has occurred
in American politics,
this book got a changed for me
because at its heart it is a story of
two miracles and it is a story of an
amazing time in the middle of the Cold
War when Russia and the United States had
40,000 nuclear weapons
pointed at each other,
and instead we buried those hatchets
and we worked together to conquer one of
the worst diseases in human history,
a disease which had killed half a
billion people in the 20th century.
When I got the Ted Prize,
I had Larry and Sergei and the audience
and I said in the year that they were
born, which was pretty
close to the summer of love,
there were 3 million people
who died of smallpox.
So it's not like it's not ancient history.
So what I'm going to do today is I'm
going to spend about 15 minutes and give
you a little story of what's in the book.
Uh,
some of the pictures and three pictures
in particular that I didn't know when I
was here working at Google existed and
I only found them using Google search.
I have a friend Ramdass some of you know
who he is and he went to the Costco and
Maui and this was the book was out
and the book was there between Bruce
Springsteen and Harry Potter. I
thought that was a good omen. Um,
Peter said I caught some breaks.
That is the understatement of my life.
Um,
in 1962,
I was a sophomore going into my junior
year at University of Michigan in Ann
Arbor and I saw a little note that Martin
Luther King was going to be on campus
and it was just a tiny little
mention in the Michigan daily.
And Martin Luther King wasn't famous yet.
They hadn't won his Nobel prize.
There hadn't been the Mississippi summer.
And I have no idea what made me get out
off my ass and go walk down to the hall
that he was speaking and see him.
And if you ever been there in Arbor,
you know that while in
the rest of the world,
rain comes vertically in Ann Arbor under
certain atmospheric conditions that
goes horizontally and you
just can't walk into it.
And it was that kind of a day and very
few people showed up for his talk.
You can see all the empty seats.
This is a hill auditorium that seated
4,000 people and there were only a couple
hundred of us. So what Martin
Luther King said was, hey listen,
that means there'll be
more of me to go around.
You all come up on stage and sit with me.
And we sat with him on that stage
and in front of him for six hours.
None of us were ever the same. We all
went down to Mississippi, Alabama.
We all joined an alphabet
soup of activist groups,
snick and core and NAACP,
SDS.
We were all changed because what he
talked about was a world not just in which
children or be judged by the
content of their character,
not the color of their skin,
not just about the arc of the moral
universe that not bends towards justice on
its own.
But you've got to jump up and grab
that arc and pull it down and twist it.
So there's something that you can
do to make the world a better place.
And none of us had ever heard that before.
I had never heard that before.
I had never heard anybody talk about the
long sweep of history and being able to
enter into it and do anything good.
Nobody had ever told me that
any of us could do that.
So that changed me. And,
and, and by the way,
I would not know that that photo
existed if it hadn't been for Google.
Because when I would tell this
story before, people said, well,
Martin Luther King never was at Michigan
and there was no record that he was
there. And, uh, when I went over
to the Skoll global threats fund,
Jeff Skoll said to me, you're
not making this shit up, are you?
He said that about a lot of things.
And I, I said, well, let's look.
And we found the Bentley historical
museum at the University of Michigan had
just gone online and this photo was just
available for the first time of Martin
Luther King going to Michigan. So, um,
I was in many ways a conventional kid.
I grew up in Detroit,
Michigan.
There were a couple of things
that were not conventional
about my wife. And, um, I,
it does bother me that that's the
picture she keeps with me hidden,
hidden behind the peace symbol.
But we were activists by then. Uh,
those of you who think
that's a Mercedes symbol,
it's almost the same
thing but very different.
And then I became a real activist and
I went to medical school and I got on a
white coat with an ostentatious
stethoscope dangling out of my side.
He used to march with Martin
Luther King and with the activist.
I was arrested with Martin Luther
King in Chicago. It's one of the,
yeah,
because pride moments of my life.
Um,
those of you who are considering
getting arrested for civil disobedience,
I want you to know,
I learned an important lesson.
Always get arrested with several
hundred of your best friends.
Cause if you're all
arrested at the same time,
they put you in pretend jail
and you can bring guitars.
Uh,
the American Medical Association in those
days said that healthcare was a not a
human right, but it was a privilege
for those who could afford it.
We said that it was a human right.
As a consequence, we were radicals.
I came to San Francisco and
did my internship. This, um,
which I also had never
seen until I googled it.
This a cover of medical
world news showed up. Uh,
and they made copies of it and put it
all over the hospital for my first day.
And uh,
they put a,
a bullseye around my face with a
hypodermic needle in my nose and it said
Presbyterian hospital welcomes
its new young radical.
Dr Radical in those days meant
that you were Bernie Sanders.
And then while I was in San Francisco,
all of you are too young to know this,
but in 1970,
a group of native Americans took over
Alcatraz because the treaty of Laramie
said that any surplus land that was
declared surplus that had been taken from
the Indians would go back to the
Indians. Long Story Short, uh,
a woman named Lou tridel
wanted to deliver her baby,
an Indian liberated land, and there
was no water, there was no electricity,
there was no medicine. And there was a
coast guard embargo around the island.
And a, the newspapers started
saying, is there no doctor?
Is there no doctor anywhere in
the area willing to go there?
And I thought that was an
add. Larry, come to Alcatraz.
So I lived on Alcatraz and I
delivered this baby named Wovoka.
If, you know, Indian history, we've,
Oco was the founder of
the ghost dance religion.
And I could not prove to anybody that
I was on Alcatraz except I was able to
Google everything I could find. And I
found that picture of me on Alcatraz.
Um,
when I came off the island,
it seemed like every,
yeah,
television camera in the world was
waiting for me when I came off on a coast
guard boat and they put it there,
camera in my face and they said,
what are the Indians want? And I had
never met a native American before.
I went on the island and Detroit,
we don't have a lot. And uh,
I have an answer,
but Warner brothers saw me on television
and offered me a job playing a young
doctor in a movie they were making
and also being the doctor for the rock
concerts that the movie was about.
So it was the Jefferson airplane,
the grateful dead Jethro tool.
We ended up with a concert for pink
Floyd in Canterbury in England.
And I was the doc for that. Uh,
my first day on the Movie Caravan,
I met this guy
and I knew there was something different
about him because when he smiled,
all of his teeth were a rainbow.
He had got a dentist to put in a
[inaudible] violet, indigo, blue, red.
And when he said, and he had a, uh, a duck
bill had I made up a real duck's bill.
I knew there was something
different about wavy gravy and I,
I'm proud to tell you that over the last
40 years he's become my best friend.
Wavy of course is known for being the
master of ceremonies at Woodstock where
he's the one who said what I have in
mind is breakfast in bed for 400,000.
He and his friends care van across Europe
and Asia providing relief in medical
care.
Every country that we went through,
we use the medicine and the food and
everybody who was sick would come out who
be 70 people waiting to see Larry.
And there was a feeling
in the year. So I want to tell
you two things about this.
One is that we went to,
uh,
we lived in Afghanistan and
Pakistan and Iran, Iraq,
India,
Nepal with those buses.
And we would do medical care
camps every place I went.
And we had a little bit of medicine,
a little bit of food.
Every place we went we going
to the smallest villages.
And if it was a Hindu village, there
would be a shrine to Lord Shiva. Or, um,
if it was a Buddhist village, there'd be
an image of Buddha was a Muslim village.
There'd be a picture of, of
Mecca. And not every time,
but maybe three out of 10 times right
next to that image in the holiest part of
the village, there would be
pictures of John F. Kennedy,
President United States in
Afghanistan and Iraq, Pakistan.
And it's going to be a long time before
there'll be a picture of an American
president in a special place in
a village anywhere in the world.
And one of the things that I
realized is I wrote this book,
I want to tell you a story that will
motivate you to believe that we can make
the world again.
The kind of place where people all over
the world will feel about America as we
felt then we were the good guys.
Let's not kid ourselves.
A lot of it was aspirational,
but we need that aspiration
and we need to have it again.
And we've done it before
and we can do it again.
And I'll tell you I was invited to,
this is my wife.
We've been married 47 years.
That was our psychedelic bus.
Uh, I think I'm smoking some
illicit substance there.
I was honored and invited to the Pentagon
and given her word and asked to speak
to the three and a half million soldiers
and sailors and Marines we have and to
talk in the Pentagon auditorium to the
army brass to generals and admirals and
assistant secretaries of defense.
And I was talking about asymmetrical
warfare and unconventional threats to
national security,
cyber weapons and biological weapons,
but also climate change and
pandemics and things like that.
And before I started my talk and the
auditorium was filled with people who I
wouldn't normally have thought of that
I'd be hanging out with when I looked
like this.
And as I showed this picture first,
and I said, I think before I talked to
you about threats to national security,
you ought to see this picture. Now,
there's only two possibilities.
Either you know about this.
Well, you don't know about this.
If you know about this,
good on you that you still invited me.
If you don't know about this,
we got big problems because
you're the Pentagon. Well,
I went from, uh, being a hippie. I had
been a radical and I became a hippie.
Then I went to live in a monastery and
this is the Ashram that I lived in.
It's Kenchi, it's at the corner
of India and Nepal and China.
And this is my guru, neem Karoli Baba.
And he's reading a book about him.
And I just had a chance,
am I allowed to say,
I just had a chance to see
virtual reality of the Taj Mahal.
And this is real reality of the Taj Mahal.
This is my wife and I in 1973
in front of the Taj Mahal.
And you know, there were no barriers
then. We actually slept inside the tomb.
We didn't know it was a tomb.
We were idiots.
And this is a picture of
my guru and myself, uh,
after I'd been living in
that Ashram for three years,
you asked me to tell that story.
I'll tell you the story of what's
happening here. He said to me,
uh, everybody who comes here learns
Hinduism and Buddhism and Jainism.
We learn Islam. We learned to read
the Old Testament, the new testament,
and then we're taught to meditate and
we're taught to do service. And he said,
Larry, he's to call me doctor
America. He said, Doctor America,
I want you to do that too,
but I want you to do something else.
How much money do you have?
And I said, wait a minute.
I was little confused. He's an
in this all in Hindi. He said,
how much money do you have?
I said, I have $500 he said,
not here. You're lying. How much money
do you have back in America? I said,
well I have a $500 back in America too.
And he said, $5 here. $500
there. That's all you have.
You are no doctor,
which is what my mother said to me.
Yeah I have is 500 bucks.
You no doctor.
But he said all of this in Hindi and he
said, you are no doctor, Doctor America,
you are no doctor. You are new doc, Toto,
Dr Nicky. And come to his afternoon,
kept saying it over again.
Then he switched to English and he said,
you are no doctor.
You are no doctor,
you n Oh doctor,
United Nations organization.
Dr America is going to
become United Nations doctor.
You're going to go to villages,
you're going to give vaccinations.
There's a war against this
disease called smallpox.
It's going to be eradicated on Mullen,
pulled out by the roots.
This is God's gift to
humanity. Get outta here. Go.
And he sent me down to the
World Health Organization,
which was a bus to drive a car on a train,
maybe 17 hours away.
And I walked in there and they said,
what are you doing here?
I looked like,
I mean I had a dress on and I had a beard
down to the middle of my back and said,
what are you doing here? I said, well,
my guru who lives in the Himalayas says
that I'm supposed to come work for the
United Nations because God's
gift to humanity and said,
we're going to eradicate smallpox.
And I was there for about
30 seconds the first time,
and I went back up to the Ashram and he
said, did you get your job? And I said,
you know, go back down. And
that went on 10, 15 times.
And each time I got a little smarter,
I trim my hair a little bit and cut
my beard a bit and put on a jacket.
And um, after a while I understood
there was no smallpox program.
Mrs Gandhi,
who was in the prime minister I think
correctly said that India had other
problems, poverty and diarrheal
deaths and pneumonia. Um,
and I felt kind of silly every
time coming in and being rebuffed,
uh, and getting back to the Ashram and
my group is saying, this is your destiny,
and it, nothing was feeling right to
me. And I walked in one day, he said,
right now, go immediately.
So I took a train,
I went in there and walked in and for the
first time in six months of going back
and forth what I walked into,
it was another American and he said,
who are you? And I said, hi, my name
is Larry Brilliant. I'm a doctor.
I live in the Himalaya is my guru.
Said this,
I'm supposed to work for
the smallpox program.
God is going to help eradicate
smallpox. Who are you? He said, Oh,
I'm the head of the smallpox
program from Geneva.
I'm just here trying to talk Mrs Gandhi
into letting us have a smallpox program.
We don't have one yet.
Um,
but should I interview
you just in case we do.
And that was da Henderson who died about
four weeks ago and I'm going to go to
his funeral in two.
He was the head of the global program and
after I had worked in that program for
10 years and I was running
the program in New Delhi, uh,
he sent me to back to close
down the program after we
eradicated smallpox and to
put all the records
together and to microfilm.
And when I found his interview
that he did with me, and he said,
I have today interviewed a young man.
He's American. His name is Larry,
says he's a doctor. It does not look
like one. He appears to have gone native.
And I treasure that.
In this book is the first book
I've ever written about smallpox.
The Da Henderson did not edit
every page, every word. So, okay.
So here's my transformation from
being a radical to being a Hippie,
to being a mystic,
to being a UN officer.
And that was my boss,
Nicole grass.
Say a French doctor who she
won the legion of honor.
In fact,
all the people that I work with,
Da Henderson and bill figgy won the
presidential medal of freedom. He Sour.
Rita won the Japan Prize, mid
Sharma Mooney, Interdev Sharma,
one pub missionary in Putnam,
booboo, Sean for the Indians here.
You know what that means?
And we went door to door trying to find
every case of smallpox in the world at
the same time and put a ring of immunity
around it because that was the only way
that you could stop smallpox,
which had so many different names.
You couldn't actually say the name.
Uh, how many of you speak Bengali?
Chonteau is spring sickness and
she Kalama cooling mother. Um,
and so we showed that little card and
we found cases of smallpox and other,
this is the part I apologize for.
I'm going to show you three pictures of
smallpox and I've chosen ones that are
not particularly terrifying,
but they will still be terrifying because
it was the worst disease in the world.
Uh,
this is a young boy in south India.
This woman died of hemorrhagic smallpox,
particularly cruel form of smallpox,
a hundred percent fatal,
ordinary smallpox was only one third fail.
And here's the computation that over
200 million deaths in this last century,
more than all the
genocides and world wars.
And here's really an important slide. This
is my favorite slide in public health.
It's all the kings and Queens and
emperors who died of smallpox.
And it's not my favorite slide because I
particularly want to kill off kings and
Queens,
but it applies to the heads of all the
great technology companies and all the
CEOs and startups in the meadow cheese
in this world we live in now and in
silicon valley because it doesn't help
you to be in the 1% or the one quarter of
1% of the one one 1% of 1% if there's
a virus that has no antiviral and no
vaccine,
you will die and these are the most
powerful people in the world and they died
of smallpox.
It's just a reminder that we're all
in it together and I'm not going to go
through all the rest of the history
of smallpox with you this time.
It's in the book and they were
had a chance to say that before,
but I will show you a picture of
the fellow, this wonderful man,
Bill faggy who created the strategy that
we used and I am I tell you about bill
because his father was
a Lutheran minister.
His grandfather was a Lutheran minister
and I've used this slide set to talk
about compassion and bill is the most
compassionate person I've ever met.
He was the head of CDC,
the head of the Carter Center.
He's rumored to have whispered
into Bill Gates his ear.
It might be a good idea to start a
foundation. He's an amazing person.
He says the countries should be judged
not by the GDP or by their wealth,
but how they treat people who
don't look like the leaders
who don't have the same color,
don't speak the same language,
don't have the same religion,
aren't living in the same town.
We should judge civilizations
and histories by the
compassion they show to those
who are most different than the rulers
and and not just different now but far
away do.
Can we look at a child in Aleppo who has
been bombed and is dying in Syria and
have as much compassion for that child
as we would for our neighbor and not just
today.
Can we think about the children,
the grandchildren and the
great grandchildren will be
affected by climate change,
by an invisible, odorless, tasteless
gas. It's going to destroy their world.
Do we have compassion going
forward and backwards?
Do we have compassion for our ancestors
and our traditions? He's a great man.
Bill fakey and I think that I will
stop there and thank you very much.
And then Peter and I are gonna talk about,
so thank you very much.
[inaudible]
I'm going to take my privilege to ask a
couple of questions then we'll turn it
over to the audience.
So, uh, one is, you know,
you went door to door giving vaccinations
when you want it to communicate some
place else. It could take days to set
up communication. Now that we have, uh,
more communication technology,
what could you do differently today
and what are the targets that we could
eradicate or,
or,
yeah,
I think it's a great question.
I'm often asked to compare the
eradication of polio with eradication of
smallpox. Um, because of course
we didn't even have telegrams.
We had telex machines and
no personal computers,
no computers, no cell phones, no phones.
If you wanted to make a long distance
call from Calcutta to New Delhi,
you had to book it two days in advance.
And if you wanted to call
from Delhi to Geneva,
you had to send a telex. I mean, um,
so we didn't have that with
him photocopying machines. Um,
but we had an incredible will to eradicate
and smallpox because on its face it's
so horrible.
It helps to generate a will to conquer it.
Polio,
on the other hand,
you can't see it unless
somebody is actually paralyzed.
You don't know it. It's it, it's
in the feces. And then the water,
only one out of a thousand kids who
get polio actually have any physical
symptoms. So it's hard to develop
that will. So the polio campaign,
which is so close to eradicating,
they've only been 17 cases of polio in
Pakistan, seven cases in Afghanistan,
two or three in Nigeria all year. I
mean, we got really that close. Uh,
they've had all the technology and
they've really done, and I'm the genomics,
some incredible advances in genomic
technology and being able to do all the
communications. If we had
had that in smallpox, um,
we probably could have cut the
time that it took us to eradicate.
And half a smallpox eradication
cost $150 million in 1960 $7,
you know,
call it a billion.
We reap those benefits
every week in the world,
not just from the lack of
suffering and the lack of disease,
but even in the little yellow cards
we used to have to carry going across
airports. I think polio eradication
is already cost about $10 billion.
So having the technology
alone is not enough.
I'll just say one more thing
about medical technology.
We had a vaccine against smallpox for
a hundred years before we were able to
eradicate smallpox. We've had a
vaccine against polio for 60 years.
It takes people more than technology.
I'm here at Google.
This may be a surprise.
It takes people more than technology.
The technological advances in medicine,
whether an antiviral or
antibiotic or a vaccine,
they are the condition precedent that
allows you to think about conquering your
disease. But in many ways,
they're just the beginning. Okay.
And then one more question. So, uh,
I was an office mate with the Mang
for awhile and then in the early days,
and we work together and through
him and others, you know,
I've worked on my mindfulness
and compassion and serenity
and I keep working at
it and think I'm making some progress,
but I've never ever achieved this kind
of spiritual enlightenment that you talk
about. And I think you were maybe
a little bit skeptical at first,
but you got there. So what am I
missing? Is it the girl is the drugs?
So is there anybody in this room
that has not had that question?
I don't mean about the
drugs. Um, you know,
you said it earlier, you said that I
got lucky. I feel that way. I mean, I,
I met a teacher who was still alive.
We only had three years before he
died, but we had, we had that. Um,
and when I sat in front of him, I
remember the first time, I mean,
I was really skeptical. I
mean, uh, a kid from a, uh,
Jewish tradition in Detroit,
Michigan, going into an Ashram,
filled with idols, touching
the feet of the guru. I mean,
these are all things I was trained.
That's the last thing you ever do.
I was waiting for a golden calf to come
out and march across the Cecil Beaton
Mil screen, you know, um, I
thought it was really weird.
And um, and then, um, one day, uh,
he held my hand for a second and I could
sense that he felt nothing but total
love, not just for me, but
for everybody in the world.
And then,
then this thing happened where my,
my rational mind,
I'm a scientist,
maybe I just play one on television,
but I pretend to be a scientist.
My rational mind couldn't figure
out what was happening to me.
I could accept that he loved everybody
in the world because that's his job.
He's a guru.
What I didn't understand is that in that
moment I loved everybody in the world
and I had never felt like that before.
I mean,
I gave a talk the other
day and I mentioned that my
friend Ron doss has a um,
like a religious table on it and he put
a picture of Trump because he's trying
to show love to somebody who
otherwise he would not feel love for.
And I think that's the thing is that
when you have that spiritual experience,
we are really all one. And, and,
and it's not just that we're 99.4,
4% the same genetic material.
It's that we really are all one.
We cannot forget that diversity is
not something that is thrust upon us.
It is the biggest opportunity that's
given to us because each one of us has a
little bit of the secret.
It's part of being a different person,
a different culture, a different
community, a different language.
We all have a little bit of that secret,
that little Harry Potter secret
map in us and that experience,
you come by by luck as I
did by years of meditation,
by childbirth, by knitting, by praying,
by being in the monastery,
by working in the street with kids,
by feeling compassionate
towards your grandparents.
I have met people who've had that
experience in every way imaginable.
There's no one way that is
the same for each of us.
We've all got our own little map that's
been given to us, our own religion,
whatever it is, is her
own, as they say in India,
at her own Dharma.
Our own destiny is better for us,
however humble than somebody else's.
And that, that's what I learned. I
learned to respect every religion.
I started studying all
religions that I could.
I started making pilgrimages
to each religion. I,
I started trying to meet people
who were very different than me
and it all came out of that
one experience. So Peter,
everybody who knows you knows you're not
missing a damn thing. You, you haven't,
nothing has alluded to.
And I think everybody who knows
you is privileged to know you.
Thank you doctor America.
Let's go to the audience questions.
Anybody? Thank you. Oh,
it's a question. Uh, Larry,
what do you think America could do to get
to a place where other countries would
feel that way about America again?
And why do they have JFK his
picture in the first place?
Um, I think they had GFKs
picture because, um, you know,
everybody and those little
villages either had a,
an uncle or a cousin who had gone to New
York or going to school in America or,
or wanted to,
because a lot of the myths that America's
streets were covered with gold was
part of it.
But it always felt like America after
the Second World War as a victorious,
an occupying power was such a benevolent
occupying power.
We didn't take,
we didn't take one acre of land
in Germany. I mean, we just, um,
it was our highest and our best moment,
I think,
and this was not 20 years
after the Second World War,
when that glow of how
well we had behaved as a
victor.
Um Huh.
That's not to excuse a lot of
the things that happened in war,
but people saw us as,
um, the sole superpower.
I mean, we were beginning this cold war
with the Soviet Union, but we were the,
on our way to becoming
the world's policeman,
but a good cop and the world wanted that.
I think we still want that.
I think we still want a good cup.
I want America to be powerful.
I want our army and our
navy to be powerful,
but only if we're going to be good cops.
I don't want us to be
powerful from the bad cops.
I want us to be good cops
and able to protect the
people who trying to do good things.
And why JFK,
his picture was there was because he
represented that moment in America when it
seemed that we were sort of like your
rich uncle who you can depend on in an
emergency or they,
she aspired to be able to depend on an
emergency and how we get back there.
It's a long way. We've done a
lot of things. It's a long way.
Um, I think we're still the best
country in the world personally,
but we don't live up to my expectations.
I hope we don't live up to anybody's
expectations. We need, we need to,
to change and try and get better
and stronger and more loving.
We, we need the kind of training
that Peter's talking about.
I grew up in India and I can testify
that I've seen pictures of JFK and all
laces, usually with the flower of
Garlin dot between his eyebrows.
But my question was about the
picture behind you, President Obama.
And it's no longer there,
but yeah,
he's in his last hundred
days of his presidency.
And I'm personally quite sad that
that era is coming to an end.
But I was wondering how you would,
how the world looks upon his legacy.
I think the Nobel prize
committee kind of jumped around,
jumped the gun. Yeah. I think
I have one picture which has,
we have two people from Google
in this picture. And, uh,
President Obama and this crazy guy
over here, and this is the group of,
uh,
Silicon Valley folks who,
when Ebola happened in, um, in,
in Africa,
in West Africa,
we had a meeting of a Google and Facebook
and salesforce and Yahoo and apple and
every other technology
company. And we, uh,
I work at Skoll Global Threats Fund
where I'm the chairman and we convened a
meeting,
uh,
and all the tech companies jumped in
to help President Obama to deliver
America's best,
to stop the epidemic of Ebola.
And then afterwards he brought us all to
the White House to thank us and this is
leadership at its best. We all
jumped in. Paul Allen jumped in,
Microsoft jumped in, it's not
just silicon valley. And we, uh,
salesforce built a, uh, a
patient tracking system and, and,
and Google gave money
in technology and uh,
Larry Lucy page gave money and soccer
Burke gave me, if everybody did,
it was a great,
I don't have to take you back to the
Cold War were Russians and Americans and
170 nations work together.
We can still do this stuff.
And we did it because
Obama called us to do it.
We did it because that's
what we're supposed to do.
That's why we're doing what we're doing.
We're not here just to write code.
We're here because we think writing code
to help make the world a better place.
All of us, every one of us, we
may forget that from time to time,
but here when children were dying and we
were seeing these horrific pictures of
Ebola,
we were willing to jump in because we
had the leadership and the means to do it
and we're going to be
asked to do that more.
All of us and we're going
to jump in and do it again.
My question was slightly different though.
I was just wondering how do you think
the world would look upon him, you know,
10 years? Oh, I think his legacy
is going to grow and we're going to
back upon him as one of the
greatest presidents in history.
I think we're going to miss
not only his intellect,
but his demeanor. I think we
did it. I don't know this,
this video will probably be
received 10 years from now,
so this will not make any sense,
but how many of you heard Michelle
Obama's talk yesterday? I mean, hello?
Let's see.
We brought the you just before you
got your advice to basically eradicate
smallpox, brought them into the future
and you are talking to the younger you.
What would you say to him in terms
of what he should be doing now?
Don't be an asshole.
I mean, I was a jerk. Um,
well just before you mean just
before I was with marriage. You know,
by then I had a lot of my jerkiness
had been beaten out of me,
but certainly growing up, um, you know,
I got to be sent to San Francisco in the
middle of the summer of love when I was
working for the office of equal health
opportunity at a card that said civil
rights specialist and I got tossed
into the summer of love. And a,
that's just not a fair thing to do to
a young kid from Detroit, Michigan.
I had no tools to resist.
But before that,
um, I don't think I was a very nice
person. I don't think I was, uh,
I don't think they ever thought
about, you know, could I,
if somebody was sick in front of me,
could I help them?
I didn't think about a
war 10,000 miles away or
I don't,
I don't think it's,
I don't think you should feel bad if
you're only thinking about yourself and
your career.
That's the natural progression.
It takes something that,
um, the changes you to make.
You start thinking about bigger things.
For me,
it was my father and my grandfather
dying and I'm feeling sorry for myself,
meeting Martin Luther King,
meeting wavy and all these
wonderful hippies in the 60s,
which was such a great experience for me.
Meeting Neem Karoli Baba go faggy.
I got to meet all these great giants who
really cared about the world and they
gradually whittled away my ass wholeness.
Well,
there's still a lot left.
I'm really touched by the moment.
When you said you wouldn't,
you touched their go to you.
You loved everyone.
You carry that with you still. Yeah,
pretty much. How do you keep it?
Um, I try to keep it safe. I
treasure it. I try to nurture it. Uh,
I was at a meeting on Friday, a at
dream force. And the guy before me said,
there's a native American,
uh, explanation for that.
And a young brave is
asking his grandfather,
how do I grow up to be wise and kind and
compassionate? And the grandfather says,
well, son, there are two
wolves inside of you.
And one of the wolves is an angry,
howling beast who would rip
your throat out if he could,
who would take your money,
who would take your children?
And the other one of these worlds loves
everybody in the world and is kind and
would share everything. And they're
battling. And the young man said,
grandfather,
which wolf will win?
And the grandfather said, well,
obviously the one that you feed,
thank you for being with us today,
Peter and Larry, thank you so much.